before the video begins I'd like to
thank you all for two years of anime
culture Corner every comment like and
frankly every extra minute spent
watching my videos means the world to me
and I couldn't do this all without you
guys I know I don't upload as much as I
used to not only is life getting busy
but I've gotten to the point where I
genuinely value quality over quantity of
my videos even if it means that you know
the views kind of suffer I I hope you
guys see this reflected in my uploads I
started off with nothing on this channel
and we've managed to come farther than I
ever could have imagined so I look
forward to many more years to come
whether you're New or Old to the channel
I'm glad you're here let's start the
video
foreign
there's something about a broken
character that speaks to us
Humanity's best attempts to relate to
literature throughout history from the
animals of Shakespeare all the way to
the bound tomes of Berserk it always
feels like the factor that ties us
together most of all is tragedy
not just any sad story the dark
backstory of an irrelevant side
character no matter how deep won't tug
on our heartstrings the same way that it
might on someone we know well implying
that our strong connection to Broken
characters isn't as simple as being just
a figment of our Collective empathy but
also includes even stronger factors like
our devotion and dedication to the
well-written character
on top of this there are innumerable
masterful stories Without Tragedy with
Incredible main characters who haven't
experienced any kind of immense sadness
that would warrant being quote unquote
broken
but I personally feel like many of the
works of fiction Manga and Anime
specifically that create a character who
I share a very strong bond with and love
so dearly all push their protagonists to
their mental and emotional limits at one
point or another
crushing their hopes destroying their
dreams and leaving them to suffer the
horrors of Life a breaking point if you
will
and so it does beg the very important
question why does breaking our
protagonists make them so beautiful
who do you think of when I say a broken
character from manga or anime guts
dorphin Aaron even all valid answers and
let me try to describe what I think
encompasses being broken before
continuing on
there are many different ways to Define
it and I don't think mine is absolutely
correct not at all but when looking at
the long list of characters like this
when I created this the common thread I
always seem to find is the lonely
struggle
not only are these characters scarred by
a certain tragedy due to external
factors or because of something they
themselves did whether it was at the
beginning of the story or something they
are forced to deal with throughout it
they also find that on their path to
Redemption that ensues they are always
utterly alone
sometimes they have people around them
still sometimes they don't but no one
ever truly understands them regardless
well no one except us
manga readers will see these characters
feelings of being misunderstood and then
attempt to relate their struggles as a
sigma male to gutses saying he's just
like me for real when they most
certainly have not had everyone they've
known and loved be brutally massacred
and or violated by their best friend who
uses them all as sacrifices in the
pursuit of godhood
but in all seriousness I think this is
an important point to make because it is
not the struggle itself that makes these
characters relatable really it's how
they cope with it and their struggle
later to express their pain emotionally
No One Alive can really understand okabe
from Stein's gate who faces the
consequences of his unchecked pursuit of
time travel a power no man should bear
the burden of possessing what allows us
to sympathize and understand him is his
inability to divulge onto others the
pain he is going through as he is forced
to travel through time for the greater
good
okabe's is a unique struggle because he
is the sole character in the world of
Steins Gate who actually can understand
across timelines just about everyone
physically wouldn't be able to
understand even if they tried
but the same Trend regardless still
follows all of our broken characters
guts is the only one who knows what the
eclipse was who Griffith really is and
the meaning behind his brand of
sacrifice
even after he's gained a new comrades
new people to love they don't really
know guts
few remember the person thorphin used to
be and those who do characters who've
been born into the Viking and Norse
climate can't understand why thorfin
wishes to repent for a life of battle he
should be proud of
why he wouldn't want to die in Valhalla
with the rest of them
these three are some of the most beloved
characters out there
so why does this shared feeling of being
misunderstood connect to us so much what
is the appeal
well there is something intrinsically
human about keeping your emotions hidden
Society shuns emotions in a way the
overtly masculine and rugged worlds of
both berserk and Finland Saga are
perfect examples of this
but some of it also does stem from our
natural desire to better ourselves and
overcome feelings on our own
a feeling of Independence and
self-imposed strength
the contrast between this internal
battle and the character's exterior adds
that depth to them
contributing to the lonely struggle
looking past the robust bravery one
needs to charge into battle or the
endurance to harden your body into an
indestructible shell hiding emotions is
something that everyone can understand
and connect to the loneliness it brings
even the strongest people people like
guts endorphin characters who are
written to exemplify that bravery and
endurance feel those same emotions and
the struggle to admit them
in a way broken characters like this
speak to us so much more because the
more broken one is the more human they
are
the more they are forced to confront the
sad truths of human society how it's
chewed them up and churned them out
forcing them to suffer though he might
not be able to feel the extent of the
tragedy itself really understand the
pain of the eclipse it is the lonely
path the characters take afterwards that
we all can share in everyone feels these
emotions of sadness tragedy that are
rooted in a basic human function so
common that even your everyday manga
reader or Anime Watcher can feel some
kind of connection
an appeal to our Humanity a broken
character isn't just one whose mind
breaks and emotions collapse and are
forced to confront the Terrors of the
world but one who also breaks the
constraints of fiction and becomes a
real genuine person in front of our eyes
we can learn how even after facing such
tragedy they can still make something of
it made up characters become a real life
source of Hope
that's pretty beautiful to me
music on today's video is all courtesy
of eachon an incredible musician and
close friend of mine check out his work
on all streaming platforms the links in
the bio
as always this has been the anime
culture corner I hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like And subscribe
for future in-depth show manga and
character analyzes and thanks for two
years
foreign
[Music]